we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail hello to the
david pakman show this is nick when your
members watch the show regularly and
your nose chill for Hillary what you do
is you gather the data you analyze it we
make sexually based decisions for what
the best possible outcome given the
circumstances could be for our country
anyway says otherwise is either
cherry-picking or lately just trying to
convince themselves something that's a
non reality yeah thanks for all you do
and keep our eyes open and Rihanna
dotnet best caller of all time instantly
but to the top of the list you're
absolutely right Nick I could not
possibly say it better myself so I won't
try on the bonus show today we will talk
about begging the question we will also
talk about apostrophe s apostrophe s or
just ' we will talk about that on the
bonus show and also a very very
insensitive halloween costume makes it
onto the walmart online store what was
the costume and what the hell was
somebody thinking all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show remember
that you can sign up for and get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at david pakman.com slash membership a
few people yesterday i mentioned this
taking advantage of this coupon code
write this down patriot for t.h.a.t are
iot 40 rachel making very copious notes
about that coupon code h eight ER iot 40
very nice discount if i do say so myself
off of membership and you will get
instant access to the bonus show we will
speak to you then